and very powerful presentation tyrus
bringing in gloria and some of the other
experts on the ground one of the guys
actually said that if you're denying
it's a crisis on the border not only are
you being dishonest you're being
dishonest with malice yeah that was
malice is always a great word when it's
used properly but there's something
about feet on the ground people are
actually living in the moment and I
think what was starting to go kind of
south I think the president was kind of
getting in a loss for words there when
he brought Gloria in phenomenal job
Gloria out there but people can feel
that they understand that and you take
the politics out and you go with the
facts on what's going on there that was
bipartisan straight up this is how it is
this is how we're dealing with it and
that's what the American people need to
see so that was great information and if
you had issues if you were just
listening to the stuff going on in
Washington after seeing that interview
you would've started thinking you know
what maybe there's something going on
it's not just hyperbole in division so
it was that was a wonderful in your PR
blood was boiling pumping and those
great hats
yeah always were more attentive when you
ever had like yeah I mean there's you
know what I'm wearing a lot this is a
you heard from the experts on the ground
30 foot fence assaults down you know
rock throwing down 65% when deployed
strategically it's very very effective
yeah and thank you President Obama
because what that section of wall was
paid for back in 2009 as a repair job by
guess who President Obama actually paid
for it saying okay because right now you
know you listen to this bluster and
Bluff coming from Trump and you say oh
it's Trump putting up that wall Trump
hasn't built any wall this is a repair
job that was funded by President Obama
look I think dana has a points always to
get out of Washington here mark the
point I'll tell you because it's really
important for him to get out because
he's had a tough week he's being sued by
20 states including California over his
emergency declaration yep they're asking
him for his tax returns and he's
struggling with that one
just today he just withdrew the
nomination of his ice director the guy
he had up for that job nobody can is
clear on it except thinking that Stephen
Miller who's behind this failed
immigration policy didn't like the guy
of course the so let me just get this
straight you said since it's Obama's
wall you like it no because you guys
focused on the idea that you had
security people there saying before this
wall was here we had a prop but guess
what that's before the wall was there
years ago is that what you're saying the
world we don't need to see this dining
sea wall except in your imagination no I
agree we don't need it all the way oh
you need it strategically right yes we
do that right there was the real-world
application of everything that is going
on that crosses borders the crisis is
not limited to nor does it begin at our
southern border one of those gentlemen
at the end mentioned not 50 billion
dollars flows only northward over and
across ports of entry almost 30 billion
dollars is profit from the for the
cartels in the drug industry since 2006
Mexico has been fighting militarily a
kingpin strategy against all of their
drug wars locally what do we think that
we're seeing it's all of the effects
from that so it's not about simply human
immigration crossing the southern border
it's because the push factors come in
south of the borders are so strong so
complicated and so now long-term
invested that that's what we're dealing
with so I love that the president also
brought in the broader conversation of
including Mexico in that because it is
about time for some diplomacy so that we
can either help or stop it yeah to hear
the the grisly reality of the drug war
talking about they find a hundred bodies
a year just buried in the desert well
that's why I think that so the president
I would keep him out on the road at
least once a week because when you're in
the Roosevelt Room or the Cabinet Room
and you bring the cameras in or let's
just say that maybe he's just headed
into Mara Lago on Fridays and he talks
to the cameras on his way out to the
helicopter
it looks repetitive yeah you have to
change the scene in order to change the
storyline
I also think that every day this week
he's had a different position on Mexico
there was gonna be closing the border
then they're not closing the border then
we think about terrorists but maybe not
for a year but maybe oh now today he is
praising the Mexican president which
maybe that actually works in terms of
getting the Mexican President to do more
but I would do this we all know that the
answer to all these problems resides in
Congress right so I focused like a laser
beam on Congress but make them follow
you
get out there get on the border or
wherever if you didn't talk about health
care wherever it's going to be don't do
it from the Roosevelt Room because it is
not effective do you think this is gonna
be a game changer like Dana said to get
out on the road change the optics and
force maybe one of these Democrat
congressmen or senators to go visit and
hear from the experts again I'll go back
to Gloria phenomenal job
it changed the conversation yep it went
from Juan's expressions like here we go
again - you know what does she talk
about well it's interesting and that's
that's important what we need and here's
the thing about the flip-flop through
the story every day I'm gonna get his
back a little bit on this one cuz I
think he's you're saying and this I
would be good I would say this is Jesse
Watters hair is off to the right I don't
like it sure it's actually off to the
left maybe we should change it next day
you know it's actually off to left so
he's listening to his people when he's
often criticized for not he'll say
something that I actually was president
that would close the border or Kaname is
gonna be a big trouble
so the next thing okay you got a year so
I'm actually okay with that because he's
known for going off the cuff he's known
from getting a little emotional and
saying well guess what we're gonna do
this and he's listening to his experts
so let's not focus off of Congress yeah
well that's what they want I wonder who
politicized this issue in the first
place I think it's not a no Trump who
said Mexico was gonna pay for this but
let me just stop for a second forget
that for a second remember spending on a
wall there's nothing to stop the
infusion of families and especially
families with children OTT talking about
an invasion we're not talking about get
we're talking about most of the people
coming right now families with children
a wall does nothing to do that it does
nothing in terms of the for added wall
in terms of the detention facilities
that are needed to accommodate these
people at this moment that's the crisis
Jesse that's the real crisis
pawns of the cartels yeah that is just a
smuggling in remember Emily this is not
mostly Mexicans these are people coming
from Central America there are different
rules in terms of asylum for the Nexus
to fit that's why I would focus on
Congress and make them fix that part
well they weren't I think Democrats want
to do something about the facilities the
detention facilities they want to do
that what Trump has done so much to
politicize it that he has a stuck